all right engine on three ninety one two
three
Noorie
you guys should point some stairs it's
kind some stairs
oh yeah so we just survived our our week
experience here at the DARPA Robotics
Challenge MIT and think has come in
sixth place after being about an inch
away from winning the whole competition
our drill slipped away from the wall
ended up being a task we couldn't
complete and that cost us the whole
challenge lost our first place spot we
were on a first place run but I think we
got to show the world that a robot based
very much on autonomy was capable of
dealing with the very best robots in the
whole world and that we're using all
kinds of tali operation and humans in
the loop there are a few defining
moments this week on our first run made
just a simple operator error where we
forgot to turn off the driving
controller before we tried to get out of
the car
we fell down broke our right arm but
even though we planned to do the entire
course right-handed the algorithms and
the operators were were able to recover
and do basically the entire course not
handed doing a seven-point run with
eight points total in a very respectable
time it was awesome awesome I couldn't
be prouder of the team the way they
handled the stress the drama the
pressure no no I'm really not used their
brains to get out of it every
inconceivable situation - I don't think
there's nothing around we could solve
all the problems we solve this week I
mean unbelievable debugging I mean odd
yeah it's that's impressive so I'm
really proud of that close man that inch